my name is Cody travillian I'm a PhD
student at Auckland University and I'll
be speaking about time-dependent
differential equation networks and
inevitably released the package
associated with it called TD diffic
units hello how is everybody
yeah good awesome my name is Cody
civilian I'm a PhD student in applied in
computational physics and today I will
be talking to you I'm at Oakland
University today I'll be talking to you
about time-dependent differential
equation networks that's gonna neva
tably be packaged up in something maybe
we'll call TD Diffie Q networks just if
Y a nice fun name my co-author is doctor
of a silt'e Berkovitz she is my research
adviser and I should note that the
preliminary code work some of the
foundational structures were built by
James Voorhees who's unfortunately left
us for industry so this is the abstract
it's a bit too read but if you'd like
it's there and it's available so
basically these time-dependent
differential equation neurons describe
the action of you know physical neurons
these can be biological or you know any
any sort of system that evolves over
time you you know you aren't locked into
the model that we show but the benefit
of biological neurons is that they
really only they really only fire when
you interact with them right so that
then gives us something like a spiking
action so here I show a series of four
neurons and they each can carry signal
from the first through to the last and
you'll see that this is a very nice
thing to have especially if you
want to set up a system of these neurons
in a network and have the signal cascade
from start to finish with as little you
know extra energy as possible I'm just
like I said these physical neurons
aren't you know limited to biological
systems and as we'll see there's other
systems that can be used beyond maybe
you've heard of like the hodgkin-huxley
model or some other fun systems that
exist but basically the reason why we
want this spiking action is that you
know the brain is awesome and it uses
spiking signals so that's why we
inevitably have something called spiking
neural networks and we'll see that these
these are kind of difficult to implement
in the basic neural network package
that's available so we built this yeah
so these networks inevitably are for
neuromorphic computing and if you're not
sure of what that is basically there are
chips that can emulate these digital
signals such that you have kind of
spiking action going from one one part
of the chip to the other but even still
these are subject some of them to the
von Neumann bottleneck which is the
separation of the memory unit and the
processing unit the brain itself has
these kind of you know intertwined the
various parts of the neuron can act
independently of one another and process
information the same as they can work
together so what we implement is
representative of this right so if
you've let's see there's you know
systems that exist right with some
various efficiencies to them here I show
that here's the human being you have
deep blue IBM
and you know alphago if you're not
familiar with deep blue this is the
system that garry kasparov fought a
valiant battle against and inevitably
lost of course then later we had alphago
where at least all fought the same
battle and ultimately lost these are of
course two very different systems deep
blue was a system of specialized
hardware there was something like 480
actual chess playing chips so in in our
current definition of kind of deep
learning and artificial intelligence
it's not really deep learning or
artificial Intel
yes it would be artificial intelligence
in that it had a library of moves that
it could cycle through very very quickly
alphago on the other hand is not
specialized hardware it's just a set of
CPUs and GPUs that consume as you can
see way more power per element than that
of deep blue IBM but alphago can play
itself from literally nothing and we get
it playing go which is kind of a bit of
a feat in itself and yeah but as you can
see with specialized hardware you can
get a lot greater efficiency than you do
with something that's more generalized
of an approach like alphago then we
actually do have some systems that are
neuromorphic chips that exist right so
there's TrueNorth
from IBM lauki from Intel and this group
at Manchester University made something
called spinnaker which actually
replicates a billion neurons it's one of
the most efficient in terms of its
elements per neuron apart of course from
the human being there they're at about
50
Samad it's about 56 neurons per sorry 56
chorus per neuron and then here we have
IBM which is I'll be efficient in the
power category that is at about 5400 and
then though he Intel just kind of you
know does its own thing over here but
here you know we're human beings we have
a one-to-one ratio of elements per
neuron and so the general conclusion is
that we have specialized hardware that's
more efficient than generalized
approaches and current hardware's
getting better over time but the brain
is way better than these so we want that
single element implementation and it
would be just very nice if we could have
that so those were nice examples of what
I would call digital neurons but what we
want to replicate our physical neurons
which are systems that we will
inevitably build in a physical space
that are not subject to digital
algorithms so they're not summations of
some thousands of cores right they are
dynamical systems that can function over
time and this is indirect contrary to
digital neurons which are just straight
input/output they don't have an internal
state necessarily that they can hold
memory in and so it's kind of like this
functional approach here where it's you
know I say f of input equals output and
there you know many element but then you
can have physical neurons that have a
stimulus response relationship and these
are you know dynamical time dependent
systems that have a memory of their
internal state and we can see that you
can represent those with the time
dependent differential equations that
I'll show and you know here it's just a
fun little equation you know
stimulus with the time dependence
response of the time dependence and you
get a change in your your output based
on the state of the internal system and
these of course we want single element
because it's yeah it's just way cooler
that way so here we see that you can
have right it's a time dependent
differential equation neuron network and
there we start using just a very general
idea of the physical neurons they're not
limited to biological systems you could
of course have the hodgkin-huxley
equation here I'm not as familiar with
that but I am familiar with with this
equation where we have some sets of
parameters that dictate the behavior of
a anti ferromagnetic and normal metal
bilayer which can function in a single
element single element orientation and
inevitably we build them out into or we
want to build them out physically into a
network and you see that you can do the
Cascade that I showed initially of
course other systems do exist but here
we have a nice relationship where you
can get the bias of the neuron in terms
of this input parameter here and that
would be something of a of an input
current from either your recognition
space or the action of the previous
neuron that is firing and so here you
can show that based on the coupling
between these neurons which would be
analogous to the weight of the
connections between them you can have a
solvable system that you can input right
into nd solve and then it runs away with
it and you can put in any kind of
adjacency matrix that you want and so it
included in this
notebook actually is all of the code
that that we've written so you can go in
and make your own time-dependent
differential equation that has some sort
of a dependent input parameter based on
the previous action of the neurons and
get coupling matrix here and then do
with it with it what you will
so it's I'll just show it for fun since
I figured out how to hide it but it's
very long set of code so if you want to
spend an entire afternoon looking
through that you're more than welcome so
basically I built out four main
functions there are various purposes to
each of them the difficu net creates the
physical system the physical neuron
Network then the net sim simulates it
the current state of the system because
you'll be able to change it with the net
train function that modifies the
physical neuron Network according to
some learning algorithm and that can be
determined by by the user what we
currently use is something of a rough
loose stochastic gradient descent like
method it's not exactly stochastic
gradient descent but that's certainly
implementable and I can detail that a
little bit further on but then we can
visualize the behavior of this system
with a difficuit function that will show
the spiking action that you saw
initially there are several helper
functions that take us along the way and
that's one of the biggest ones is this
graph layer list that kind of
algorithmically organizes things and you
have some other style plots and some
really fun things this is this last
function is something for the future
you haven't been able to get the multi
level perceptron method running but if
anybody would like to contribute to that
they are certainly more than welcome to
and I would love to talk to them about
it so as we continue here right we have
the synapse matrix and here I set some
input this adjacency matrix and then you
have an input current that you set each
of your neurons to so this is that
simple use case that we saw initially
the for neuron chain and then you have
basically you just set a reference to it
and you can get all of these beautiful
equations to fall out of it and this is
all as a result of nd solve well
actually these these are what we input
into nd solve and this can be as big as
you know as big as you can imagine
barring the the efficiencies of nd solve
we have done you know random real
populated weights of V the adjacency
matrix and solved thousand by thousand
matrices and you know matter of seconds
because and Esau is pretty awesome so
here I showed the connectivity matrix as
we call it that's the description of the
synapses between them between each of
the neurons and then you have the
connectivity matrix here then of course
you can take a look at what you get out
of it which is the series of
interpolating functions that nd solve
makes readers and conditions and and
different things there but the fun thing
is that we can have these plots Auto
populate I believe yes here we are so
that was a redo of the you know the
output that was already there
nothing too special but we see that the
spike carries from each of each neuron
to the next and this is a measure of
some abstracted parameter in the
physical system that was described by
the differential equation so if we want
to look at kind of the general algorithm
for the net train function the outputs
kind of randomly selected from the input
vector we simulate it then we compare
that against the desired output and
calculate the error update the current
vector or connectivity array and then
the method is ceased after either a
defined number of iterations or when you
have an error of zero which probably
represents an overtrained system but
here I show a connectivity matrix for
and and one for or and if we wanted to
kind of see what these look like you can
just plug them into the style the JSON C
plot and get out this kind of and
looking gate these are what would what
would be called input input neurons and
then here's kind of this hidden space
and then you have the output neuron here
then if we want to train these and
actually the the colors here are
representative of the you know the the
weights of the neurons and let's see if
okay so
I am much like maybe some others don't
like yes ah okay here we are
so we have this trained and synapse
matrix and you see that you know you
have a zero one you get out zero I want
zero you get out of zero and if you have
a one one look at that
you get a one that's exactly what we
want and that if you want to believe it
or not that trained the system and
something like thirty ybox using the
synapse method so this is all built out
in this notebook and it's ready for
people to to experiment so here I train
the same system the same initial system
actually I'm inputting the and matrix
here and so I get the 0 1 the 1 0
there's zero one outputs the 1 ones your
outputs the 1 and the 1 1 outputs the 1
so this is all very good and that's
using adjustment of the weights then
here I can show the same process
occurring with the the current trainer
which is albeit a bit more unstable but
still still pretty awesome so you get
the zero one get the zero one zero zero
one one one we all know we all know
truth tables right so then same thing
and put the an matrix and I get this
this or function coming out so you know
you can do and an or pretty easy and
it's you know more or less user-friendly
once you wrap your head around it there
are of course more improvements that can
occur but you have this big input vector
space and you have the the inputs and
the output the desired outputs and that
should be relatively easy for anyone who
wants to use it to to use it so here we
can show the effect of you know a zero
one input
just by executing the plot functions and
you see that there are spikes that show
up and then the position of these this
abstracted parameter here if we wanted
we could see what happens when we switch
these naturally show that this is not
too much of a parlor trick and you get
the other neurons firing so if you see
the colors stay the same but the other
neurons fire here and here they are with
their parameters progressing across the
space that we want them to so we can do
the same thing for ore which is maybe a
little bit more visual when you want to
switch it so we'll get that ready
see what happens
okay so we see the previous output down
here and we will get a new output after
that and it's exactly what we saw before
but of course different colors so the
big change is when you have the the one
in one and you see them all fire and
then you really recognize that it's a
system system of neurons and here we
have the v one firing and we see that
you know it's actually they're all
firing at the same time so it's a little
bit difficult to see but none of them
are left down here
not having fired so this is good and a
little bit more advanced of an
application of this which can inevitably
be something of a basic approach would
be an xor gate and that's kind of the
the lowest level test for if your if
your network can do something like a non
linear approximation of some function so
here I'm running it for about 200 epics
and I see that when I have two initial
inputs I get out no output then I have
something it's a 1 0 and I get the 1
this this these last two are inevitably
firing to a final output neuron that's
appended at the end and so then here I
have 0 1 and I get 0 1 which then these
ones propagate forward and I get this
final output here which we see you have
2 1 inputs you get 0 & 1 0 you get 1 0 1
and you get you know 1 which is awesome
and we can visualize this of course with
the same functions and see that the
system behaves as we want it to behave
so here we have the inputs and they're
firing and we have the seventh neuron
firing which is our desired output the
parameters process across the space and
this is good then we can show that this
next input is different and you can
really do any sort of system that you
want so here I'm firing both of them
well one and zero and we get this output
so it's it's a really versatile system
and you can kind of do if it what you
will
yes this is the zero one so that was the
one one which is why we didn't see the
seventh neuron fire and we have a zero
on input and we'll see vd7 neuron fire
which is a good thing and our system
works like we trained it to yeah this
was a very long time coming so basically
the the key takeaway from this is that
you have spiking neural networks and
those working with neuromorphic
computing are becoming way more popular
they're more efficient and more
versatile than then you know traditional
neural network approaches physical
neuron networks are gonna be central to
efficient spiking neural networks and if
we can have a single element
implementation of specialized hardware
that's that's what we want so thank you
to the Wolfram language that can do that
a few emails here yeah so here's the
things yeah
[Applause]